welcome to this video playing
international Marcel killer chess like
those subtle names no name in there okay
so it's the killer chest but it does not
want to say who is let's see you the
night off okay yeah we have a very vague
idea of those lines hmm maybe queen
somewhere here I don't I don't know does
not even have a flag and am NOT not a
name and not even a flag okay how to
proceed yeah I guess I should advance
some points here that what Jay that's
what they usually do not know not really
a know the precise line opposition but
it's usually some point pushes okay well
be for oil before night x ey I don't
want that v5 the risk we should be seven
coming
hmm
there's some syntactically tactical way
to to go about that
I don't really see him see one lucky
five or something i didn't i didn't
really see that as a possible option
I thought that maybe after before I can
play knight at 5-4 just probably
ridiculous but it was my idea okay
here's some I'm just playing Bishop e7
jam before continues to be a problem
really I don't know check interesting
okay no but I thought at least here I
don't have this immediate problem only
for any more after he took on b3 but of
course it's got two bishops that's not
bad two bishops against two nights and
yeah well okay I saw that the things but
I cannot really count this type of the
pawns anymore
check
yeah you would like to play 95 and Joe
but it's probably not really a serious a
serious sacrifice at least objectively
speaking it should work but do I want to
retreat really to e2 maybe maybe it
allows f4 and further pushes but yeah
it's certainly not good for white yeah
that sometimes happens if I try to play
you for the open Sicilian hmm I really
don't know the precise theoretical um
yeah ins and outs and then sometimes you
just get this type of stuff when you
have problems really quickly I think you
can just take you for I mean it's it's
maybe a bit risky but still maybe bishop
efore night afore maybe this is an idea
the ship cakes look change I know I
thought f4 actually
yeah he does not have to do any of that
he can probably play em many other moves
yeah and now will this a thought of
night f4 could be an idea but I came he
probably can also just play d 5 this was
my original intention and then g5 takes
night XD five he must reckon with with
night to e6 and I think this is really
working yeah 96-hour okay see two hands
mc2 were saying okay well I thought that
that's also rook rook here and 96 and I
will do that this is this is really
interesting takes Queen takes is just
good for what I think unless a one less
he can play yeah anyway I need to do
this that's not not much to argue here
takes Queen takes King of a drupe t7 I
thought but there is some Queen takes a
form with a check ok I can go to a Jew
and I'm threatening Queenie 7 g7 made
hmm it does not really have a defense
against it maybe we'll create okay well
I I expect him to move the Queen anyway
I know it gets tricky i think but chats
pretty clear that now i have a
substantial compensation
okay the question is watch now that's
even f5 f5 is also very serious move f5
f6 or something else I Scott Brooks e8
himself rook c8 f5 Roxy 896 check takes
Queen edge Simon is not that's not
winning really
okay i need tools
bit of a gambler really rook c8 I don't
know what I do against it he may be can
take it f6 check completely forgot that
he can go back haha I thought it's
thought King g8 oh wow check
alright still it's very tricky if as you
can see check check check can i play for
winsome ln c 6 is very dangerous rookie
5 checkmate whoo yeah okay this was sad
Oh certainly totally lost at some stage
oh it's time you've all played yeah at
least well well tricked or whatever not
really well played very nice of him but
probably more of a big swing low it was
difficult to play suddenly it so it's
not too easy let's let's go through it
just briefly with the comp I mean it
probably will show many mistakes and to
g5 yeah I must do that this is pretty
much clear but the question really is a
check here the other computer wants to
take check
wants to take and now Queenie 7 check
yeah well something like that no idea it
this hmm no idea very unclear computers
on 000 and the decent evaluation you
will only get with investing much more
time this is this is now winning
according to the to the machine with
night f5 okay sort of like the normal
move I I didn't really know what happens
after that I'm just here mmm okay okay
okay yeah now that's wrong text the
Queen defense e2 and if the Queen the
Queen must move somewhere i'd protects
the rook so back and then i have stuff
like g6 queen age 6 this is a
tremendously strong booth he cannot take
it check I'm threatening this
threatening this it's winning neither
fine okay this is so just probably a
bluff he took it check and end him
winning I'm getting with this this is
fun this is great I didn't plan it I
didn't plan any of it very lucky he
cannot take it and this is when I check
check yeah well g6 was was good that I
spotted that there was the absolutely
last shot and it's winning this is
winning for what unbelievable stuff yeah
that's why sometimes playing an opening
like the chances so eunice a good idea
it leads to stuff that you won't get in
the slovaks change or something that's
really fun yeah just coincidence just
very lucky that this was was a chance
working yeah auntie em check
i probe jab some I what it keeps the
wind check it is computer as giving a
winner all the way yeah wow that was
cool he really here I'll play me in the
opening already but it still wasn't it
wasn't totally clear probably I'm not so
sure really about this this um check
this bishop this takes maybe here here
before maybe before first or something
it this is not a good position for white
pretty sure about that and not not just
because I just have this preference for
bishops it's justice does not look right
but a very fun end of the game I hope
you enjoyed it thanks for watching